Wenn es um K.o.-Tropfen geht, sind die Schlagzeilen
absolut verstörend und schockierend: Die
Betroffenen sind willenlos, gelähmt oder
gar bewusstlos und können sich an nichts
mehr erinnern.
Dann werden sie bestohlen oder Opfer von sexuellem
Missbrauch.
Und die Dunkelziffer ist extrem hoch.
Doch es gibt Möglichkeiten, sich vor K.o-Tropfen
zu schützen… Und sogar ein spezielles Armband,
das aber ein Haken hat.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - Los geht‘s!
herzlich willkommen!
Eine Sache ist ganz klar: Schuld haben einzig
und allein die Täter.
Doch viele Menschen, die Opfer von K.o-Tropfen
werden, schämen sich.
Und suchen die Schuld bei sich selbst.
Das ist einer der Gründe, warum es keine
verlässlichen Statistiken darüber gibt,
wie viele Menschen pro Jahr Opfer von K.o.Tropfen
werden.
Ich selbst habe mal, wohl versehentlich, eine
Portion abbekommen.
Der nächsten Morgen war extrem seltsam.
Aber manche Betroffenen merken es aber auch
gar nicht oder zu spät, dass sie Opfer von
K.o.-Tropfen geworden sind.
Im Blut und Urin kann die Substanz nur wenige
Stunden nachgewiesen werden.
Das Bundeskriminalamt geht von einer hohen
Dunkelziffer aus.
Die Hilfsorganisation “Weißer Ring” berichtet
auf seiner Website von solch einem schrecklichen
Fall: “Als Nina frühmorgens in einem Münchener
Park zu sich kommt, auf dem Boden liegend,
die Kleidung verrutscht, der Slip in den Kniekehlen,
ist sie zunächst verwirrt.
An die vergangenen Stunden kann sie sich nicht
erinnern.
Was sie noch weiß: Sie war in einem Klub,
hat getanzt, sich amüsiert, mit Fremden geredet,
Drinks ausgegeben bekommen – eigentlich
ein ganz normaler Abend.”
Quelle: https://weisser-ring.de/presse-social-media/kampf-gegen-Ko
Die Bezeichnung K.-o.
Tropfen kommt aus dem Englischen - “Knock-out”,
was so viel heißt wie: “außer-Gefecht-setzen”.
Und das bringt es wirklich gut auf den Punkt:
Ein kompletter Blackout ist die fatale Folge.
Vor allem der Gedächtnisverlust ist typisch
und die Opfer können sich einfach an nichts
mehr erinnern.
Genau das macht es den Tätern so leicht:
Oft mischen sie die Tropfen in Clubs oder
Bars in Getränke - und in der Partystimmung
bleibt dies meist unbemerkt.
Die Tropfen selbst sind geschmacksneutral
und zudem sind sie farblos, sodass es nicht
möglich ist, diese Gefahr auf den ersten
Blick zu erkennen!
Und genau das macht sie so gefährlich.
Doch es gibt eben nicht nur das EIN K.o.-Mittel,
sondern rund 140 Substanzen, die missbräuchlich
als solches eingesetzt werden können.
Der Großteil dieser Substanzen ist übrigens
legal und wir sogar therapeutisch eingesetzt:
beispielsweise als Beruhigungs- oder Schlafmittel.
Durch eine Überdosierung und die heimliche
Gabe werden diese Substanzen dann zu K.o-Tropfen.
Drei chemische Stoffe sind in diesem Kontext
besonders oft zu hören: Die Substanz GBL
(Gamma-Butyrolacton) und BDO (1,4 Butandiol),
die beide in Europa legal sind sowie das illegale
GHB (Gamma-Hydroxybuttersäure).
Letzteres ist illegal.
Bei Überdosierung und in Zusammenhang mit
Alkohol besteht Lebensgefahr, da ein Atemstillstand
hervorgerufen werden kann.
Doch es gibt Möglichkeiten, sich vor K.o.-Tropfen
zu schützen.
Wichtig ist es, das Glas oder die Flasche
nie unbeobachtet lassen und keine offenen
Getränke von unbekannten Menschen annehmen.
Sobald man sich unwohl fühlt, sollte man
Bekannte, Freunde oder das Personal der Location
ansprechen und um Hilfe bitten.
Für Kim Eisenmann aus Karlsruhe war das aber
nicht genug.
Sie hat zusammen mit ihrem Freund ein spezielles
Armband entwickelt, mit dessen Hilfe man Drinks
auf bekannte K.o.-Tropfen testen kann.
In einem Interview (mit “Orange/Handelsblatt)
erklärt sie, wie sie auf die Idee dazu kam:
“Im vergangenen Sommer war ich mit meinem
Freund Sven auf einem Stadtfest und dort wurde
eine Bekannte von uns Opfer von K.o.-Tropfen.
Nachts wurde sie dann in einem Park gefunden,
sie konnte sich an nichts erinnern und war
schlimm verletzt.
Das war für mich ein totaler Schock, weil
wir auch auf dem Fest waren und es genauso
gut mich hätte erwischen können.
Die Gefahr hat sich einfach so nah angefühlt.
Man denkt immer, mir und meinen Freunden kann
so etwas nicht passieren.
Bis es dann doch passiert.”
Ein bekannter Drogeriemarkt (dm) hat Kim Eisenmanns
Armband in die Vermarktung genommen - und
die Nachfrage im Online-Shop ist groß.
Das Armband ist weiß und strahlt hell im
Schwarzlicht der meisten Clubs - manche Täter
werden im besten Fall dadurch schon abgehalten.
Wenn man aber den Verdacht hat, dass mit dem
eigenen Getränk etwas nicht stimmt, rührt
man den Drink um und gibt einen Tropfen auf
das Testfeld des Armbandes.
Wenn K.o.-Tropen enthalten sind, färbt sich
das Testfeld blau.
Ein Armband reicht aus, um zwei Getränke
zu prüfen.
Doch Vorsicht: Denn längst nicht alle Substanzen
werden mit diesem Armband abgedeckt.
Es spricht nur auf den gängigsten Typ von
K.o.-Tropfen - GHB- an und ist somit kein
Vollschutz gegen sämtliche Drogen.
Doch eine Weiterentwicklung ist geplant, damit
auch andere Stoffe erkannt werden können.
Auch die Politik ist an dem Thema dran.
Eine Möglichkeit wäre es, das Arznei- oder
Betäubungsmittelgesetz zu ändern, um so
den Umgang mit entsprechenden Substanzen einzudämmen.
Diskutiert wird zudem auch, die entsprechenden
Substanzen mit Bitterstoffen zu versetzen,
damit sie unbedingt heraus geschmeckt werden
können.
Dazu Sozial- und Integrationsminister Manne
Lucha nach der Gesundheitsministerkonferenz
der Länder im Juni diesen Jahres (2019):
“Wir haben das Bundesgesundheitsministerium
aufgefordert, geeignete Regelungen zu treffen,
um die missbräuchliche Herstellung von K.O.-Tropfen
einzudämmen.
(...) Wir müssen Wege finden, die missbräuchliche
Verwendung von Substanzen, die eigentlich
zur Herstellung von medizinischen oder industriellen
Produkten gedacht waren, zu verhindern”.
Mindestens genauso wichtig ist aber die Prävention.
Dazu ein Sprecher vom “Weißen Bund”:
„Den Enkeltrick gibt es inzwischen zum Beispiel
seit mehr als 20 Jahren und er funktioniert
immer noch.
Wir müssen auch bei K.-o.-Tropfen dran bleiben”.
Und wo bekommt man die K.o.-Tropfen?
Zum Beispiel im Darknet.
Drogenkriminalität im Darknet.
Cooles Video von breaking Lab.
Anklicken, anschauen und den sehr coolen Kanal
Breaking Lab abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!